let's just get into this this is going
to be episode number 10 of the beginner
to master speedrun unlike previous
episodes I'm live streaming on
Twitch uh YouTube can say hi to the
twitch chat maybe twitch chat can say hi
to the Future YouTube audience welcome
to everyone tuning
in in the the present and in the future
maybe the past as well so the goal today
is to keep raising the rating uh coming
in rated
829 and hopefully we'll have a bunch of
instructive games I have updated my
profile
picture to uh a new slightly older
version of
myself and let's waste no more time
let's get into
it playing Lancers
309 now the danger is because I'm
streaming this live it's possible I
could be playing a
viewer and uh okay first game get
supported oh
no okay playing a
bzowski from the country of
Indonesia slamat pagi I think it's
morning there let's play um D4
D5
and yeah most of the games I played in
this speedrun feature E4 so this is a
bit different Knight C3 is not the most
popular
move uh more often people play the
Queen's
gabit sometimes when people play Knight
C3 it's a sign that they'll play joob
Bava London uh Bishop G5 is also
playable uh lee chess is calling this so
trow or chess.com is calling this the
chowski attack I think this has another
name though too maybe like a ver
s so against this
move like one of the points for white is
White's threatning to take and then try
and double my pawns if I play E6 and the
knight's pinned so the move I like to
play here is Knight to
D7 and even though it blocks a
queen my n on F6 still defends a pawn
and of course it takes and I can take
back with the Knight and I got the two
Bishops and I'm not damaging my
structure and from here Life Will Go
On um I do want the castle hopefully
pretty soon but if I play E6 on it
blocks a bishop so I think I'm happy to
play Bishop F5 here and then idea is E6
and Bishop D6 and
castle and that will actually kind of be
uh reverse
London where I mean the London system is
basically this except I don't have a
knight coming
here Bishop B5 check okay happy to play
C6 I have noticed like a lot of
beginners sometimes like to throw in
this check sometimes you get the the
dopamine Rush of attacking your
opponent's king but uh in that case it
didn't really do much my Pawn is is
happy to be
here wow
G4 so I can't take it cuz it's supported
by the Queen Bishop battery
like here it's a choice between Bishop
E4 or Bishop
G6 I think I just want to drop back
don't want to play this and allow white
to take away my
Bishop but White's playing very
aggressively uh with
H4 white is threatening to play H5 and
then eventually trap the
bishop so I do have to be
careful the two ways to deal with this
are H5 or or
H6 I think both moves are pretty
acceptable H5 is a bit more
confrontational like I would allow the
exchange which I think is okay
actually if H5 it also allows G5 but
then Knight can move
back I'll go for
H5 this might be the strongest play I've
played in like this whole speedrun
series so I don't think I've played
anyone over a thousand
yet and they have not made any like
obvious
mistakes maybe some subtle inaccuracies
like trading the bishop early on this
whole
expansion it's hard to punish right away
and it really EMB balances the
position but I'm just trying to be solid
I'll play Bishop to
D6 completing
the the so-called London like triangle
setup wow so White
Castles into the side where the pawns
have already
advanced and this is a move which I'd
imagine should be
punishable but it's still a question
like how to orchestrate an attack
on the king
side like I could kind of poke and prod
with
F6 I'm not sure if F6 really thrs
much another idea is to like play E5
either now or maybe play Queen E7 and
eventually play
E5 I'm really just looking
for my options first of all like if I
play E5 first takes and takes and takes
and takes and we're trading the very end
there maybe white plays F4 I don't think
I'm getting that
much so I'm going to play Queen
E7 kind of as a multi-purpose
[Music]
move on one hand I'm giving more support
to E5 but I'm also preparing to Castle
Queen side then hopefully connect the
Rooks we see Bishop
D3
that's actually a reasonable
move because if I allow takes I have to
take back with the pawn I think this is
a time to
calculate a little
bit cuz I would really like to get an E5
and if takes takes maybe it's not so
bad like take and then take and then
take and then take I'm threatening mate
if F4 there I can take with
check
yeah I think I'll go for
this it is maybe a bit unnatural to
allow my pawns to be doubled and a
situation where I take away from the
center but I like the prospect of just
opening up the
lines give the F and E files open and
eventually I would like to Castle and um
just exert maximum pressure on the
files but why he plays E4
wow so it's getting
spicy yeah my opponent's not afraid to
spice things
up I mean the first move that comes to
mind is
taking I have to watch my time
too taking would attack the
Knight and if takes back then I have
this move threatening
mate and there's also takes takes and
takes
let's start with this I do have to be
careful that my queen and king are
aligned on a file that is very likely to
be open very
soon so like if I do take white could
probably take take take and if I take
with Queen there's Rook e one in the
very
end which makes me more inclined to like
Castle quickly if I played this move it
looks good attacking the knight in mate
but then there's Knight
F3
so maybe I'll take
once just relieving the
tension I'm not going to
take two more
times but depending what white does I
might Castle
next and queen E5 still could be an
option down about 3 minutes on the
clock very interesting game so
far
white has options here I was going to
say Rook e one was maybe
possible but we see Bishop E2 so I think
my opponent didn't see the Tactical idea
with Rook
E1 and
now I mean queen
E5 how does white
defend let's do
it like moments like this with my time
getting low I just want to try and keep
the
pressure then think on my opponent's
time I think the best try for white is
to play
F4 and then I can on
aan but it's not winning because okay
well now it's winning cuz
Checkmate um I should show though that
it could have been still tricky like
F4 I would take Knight would take Queen
G3 it does look good for black
but I don't think there's any obvious
win cuz Knight defends
[Music]
H2
so maybe it's possible F3 was a mouse
slip probably more likely my opponent
just didn't realize a
threat so I mean my opponent definitely
played like a very interesting game I
would say they they're underrated for
the way they play
um going forward I think more common in
this
opening at least stronger players who
I've played against will play F3 and
then
E4 uh a more direct way of trying to
challenge the
center and then
later yeah all of this was
interesting E4 was especially like super
spicy thank you for the
raid risk GMO
Olive but yeah I think this position
white should have taken and then just to
show if takes takes I can't really go
into this cuz my queen gets
lost so I think the plan like if white
did
this maybe I would take once and then
play Queen side
Castle oh but then Knight
here
[Music]
ooh so maybe I would Queens side Castle
immediately
or maybe I would just blunder and then
lose who
knows anyway um nice game to start the
episode
so yeah let's move on playing
JN
something and I've been sticking with a
lot of similar openings so far the
series uh D3 it's a playable move not
the most active move it does kind of
shot in the bishop
generally in these King Pawn openings
you want to develop the bishop and then
form the pawn
chain here it looks like White's trying
to
play some kind of like King's Pawn
version of the London except this bishop
is going to be stuck and generally F3 is
not a great
move uh especially because it allows the
bishop to pierce through the
position and yeah generally in King's
Pawn openings a knight does like to
develop
[Music]
here with Knight
E2 I'm looking for ways to punish
White's play like as quickly as
possible I think the best way
to quote unquote punish white is just to
follow principles like just develop
naturally control the
center likely going for D5 very
[Music]
soon uh in this
position uh that's actually a
interesting
move yeah in this
position I'm going to take a
pawn I think I'll explain this move in
just a
moment oh my
queen oh
[Music]
no
okay is that the first oh no my queen of
the
speedrun I should note that like doing
the speedrun series I don't really want
to go for like dubious play to try and
trick my
opponent but in this position Knight
takes E4 I think is actually the best
move because it threatens mate and
threatens the
bishop and yeah uh White's in big
trouble here CU if Knight's taken I take
the bishop and I win a pawn in the
process let me just let's check this
with the engine real
quick yeah we have the
evalar yeah night Tak E4 is a actually
pretty clean
tactic so hope people enjoy this one
it's a pretty typical pattern this is
one example of what we call the G mate
see people mentioning it in twit chat
where you do give away the queen but you
create the May
threat and yeah here White probably
should have taken the
Knight but life was still very very
good there are cases though I should
explain that like there's some cases
where white will have this Knight
developed and let's say this is a
position then here Knight takes E4 is
actually not a good move for black even
though I could still say oh no my queen
someone call ambulance and then not for
me but um the reason why Knight takes E4
is not good here is because Knight takes
defends a bishop and then I just lose a
piece so anyway hopefully this uh
enlightens players who haven't seen this
before or need a
refresher but let's move on to another
game playing Marco
schul I'll play E4
and we have a
scandy a scandy is definitely a popular
opening at lower levels even at higher
levels um more common is Queen digs D5
Knight F6
is also very playable
move and in this
position like there's a few approaches
for white I could try and hold onto the
pawn but then there's some weird gambits
which allow black to like develop pretty
rapidly so I'm just going to play the I
think most traditional most natural move
Pawn
D4 the aim is to control the center get
ready to develop my Bishops and here
I'll start with Knight to
F3 and very often especially when the
Knight takes then I can expand with C4
control space gain time on the
Knight think there's no reason to wait
play C4 right away
and it is kind of refreshing having a
different type of opening cuz so many
games in the speedrun have been like
Kings Pawn opening and um lot of
like just early mistakes with opponents
bringing out their Queen
early but this is something a little bit
new and the same opening principles
still apply like I want to develop my
minor pieces
as quickly as possible control the
center Castle
quickly and black has now move the
Knight one two three
times so being a little bit inefficient
with development but there's been no
major mistakes from black thus
far yeah so we see Bishop to
G6 and it is actually a question here
like how to proceed with development cuz
there's a lot of natural developing
moves I think a lot of players would
play Bishop
D3 which does aim to
Castle um I'm going to play Bishop E2
which may seem a little bit more
passive but there's a few reasons for
having the bishop on E2 rather than D3
like on D3 it blocks the queen from
defending the
pawn which can sometimes be a Target
like with black potentially having a lot
of attackers
and then also on D3 it would just stare
into this Pawn chain which is super
solid for
black so I'd rather the
bishop kind of preemptively deal with
the this bishop G4 move like if black
tries to pin it's not actually a
[Music]
pin black is applying a bit of pressure
against the pawn um but there's only two
attackers I have two Defenders so black
can't win the pawn right
away
and in this position um like I think the
most natural approach would be something
like Bishop E3 or Bishop
F4 I would like to play Bishop E3 but
then there's this move Knight
G4 which I don't think I want to deal
with not to mention there's many cases
where Bishop G4 can
happen I should note here there's a move
D5 which would kick away the
Knight but sometimes playing D5 will
eventually be met with E6 which the the
pawn is a bit overextended there so I'm
going to play a move
here which maybe seems a little bit
slow but it's very
restrictive it prevents Bishop
G4 and It prepares to play this without
allowing Knight
G4 and I'm trying to deprive this B
Bishop of a good Square we see E5 okay
so this might be the first big mistake
but E5 might be playable
too I mean there's two moves that
immediately come to mind of course I can
take and it wins the pawn CU I have two
attackers only one
Defender if I take on E5
though black will take I'll
take
and then Knight
[Music]
D7 I might lose the pawn
back if I take with Knight then like
there's Knight takes D4 even Queen takes
[Music]
D4 I'm taking a moment
here I'm liking this move D5 now so it
basically forces Knight to move and then
I can
take let's go for this
this could get a little
bit little bit tricky because when I
take the
pawn uh then my Knight's undefended and
the bishop will be aligned there might
be some
discoveries I think it should be
okay oh we see the counter
attack yeah so with
this both Knights are hanging I can make
the first
capture I can imagine for a lot of
players this this would be kind of
complicated to
calculate but very simply we can imagine
takes
takes I take back I'll win a pawn and
then support the C Pawn I mean if Queens
get traded I don't mind getting the Rook
to the open file so I think this is
pretty
clean I mean the position is
transforming a lot oh someone was asking
what if black pushes a pawn presumably
to E4 so we are seeing what
happens um briefly considering this move
but that would not be advisable let's
take the
queen so things have been
traded and now there's this
tension yeah so recapture the
pawn and I'm only up a pawn here uh it's
a three on two
majority with a rook coming here my Pawn
is a bit tied down my Bishop side down
to defending the
pawn so still a lot of work to be done I
don't want to play a move like B3
which weakens a
diagonal even though it might be
interesting to
consider there's an idea here
which I'm really drawn to like I did
just say my Bishop's tie down to
defending the
pawn but I could move the bishop and
make pretty big
threat yeah let's do
this allowing black to take the pawn at
first maybe it looks like I'm just
trying to win this Pawn which I guess in
this case maybe I
am I was also going to say that Bishop
C5 was threatening to trap this
Rook actually I can't take the pawn
right away because takes I really don't
want to give up the two Bishops for a
rook but I probably don't mind
trading and I'm going to be super safe
I'll just play Rook
B1 holding on to the pawn I'm also
getting off the diagonal so like very
soon I'll probably like to play B3 and a
position like this like as we're
simplifying and whites up a pawn I just
want to be solid watch my
clock sometimes the first thing to pay
attention to is what does opponent want
to do what are the potential weaknesses
in my
position I also still want to exploit
weaknesses in Black's
[Music]
position I like the idea here of Knight
A4 Knight could find a knight Square on
C5 also combines well with the
bishop and this is a very stable
construction yeah let's just keep going
for
trades this move I'm essentially forcing
the trade of
knights I have seen like a few comments
over the course of the speedrun
episodes uh not really people
complaining but I think people saying
that there hasn't been so much endgame
instruction like with a lot of the games
I I win out the opening or middle game
uh but this game is already getting into
the end game so hopefully there will be
some endgame lessons to provide
here and I'll try and show like an
instructive way how to convert an extra
Pawn now tactics are still relevant and
my opponent actually just walked into a
pin which I think I'm happy to exploit
like let's move
F4
pretty
straightforward always have to watch out
for the check but then I just take
it it's important that my rook's
defended here yeah sometimes like even
in end game you just want to be patient
put your pieces on good squares and that
was not much of an end game
unfortunately did I jinx
it still a nice game though and goes to
show that like patience is key I think
my opponent
my opponent maybe didn't quite know what
to do here tried to make things
complicated but
E5 think made life a bit easier for
me um it's possible that my opponent
should have played
97 and I wasn't sure about this
variation because like if I take on
E5 black could take on
D5 it's a nice way of like winning back
the pawn and then attacking my
undefended Knights and maybe this would
just be a big trade and then life goes
on so okay making
progress rated
862 if anyone in twitch chat has
questions about the game so far about
life in general I could take a small
break does H3 weaken the king side in
the long
run uh there's cases where yeah like
moving the pawn in front of the king can
sometimes make like create weaknesses in
this case not really like each three has
way more
benefit and like in the long run it's
usually a useful move because it gives
Loof to my king and just takes away the
square um sometimes if you have like H3
and you don't have a pawn in F2 like if
the Pawn's gone or committed to F3 or F4
then it can weaken G3 but this structure
is still like very very
solid but if I play a move like G
G3 this could be a bit more weakening
because of the light squares allows for
Bishop
H3 so yeah very often you have to ask
yourself like what the weak squares
could be or whenever you move a pawn you
should ask yourself like are you
weakening anything and can the opponent
exploit
it okay doing one
more at least one
more playing death play
oh okay this
is this is an opening I've been getting
used to
recently oh but my opponent's not
playing Bishop
C4 I wonder if that was a mouse slip
maybe they want to take and
still like exploit the pawn that's
interesting um I mean I could play G6
because the Pawn's defended I would
attack the
queen I think here like because White's
not threatening checkmate
it just makes sense to develop bring out
the Knight attack the queen attack the
pawn not giving white time to
take and now I can keep the initiative
I'll play Knight
D4
attacking a bunch of different
targets and the queen is tied down to
defending both the pawn and the
bishop so this is a case where we can
say the queen is
overworked and if I want
to guess I have to think about this
though cuz if I take the
bishop then white takes back I take the
pawn then I I'm not actually winning
anything cuz White's going to win the E
Pawn if I take here and take and then
take and then
take yeah maybe I'm not winning
anything
so there's another idea
here like rather than trying
to like trade
and exploit the overworked
Queen there's an idea to just accelerate
development and expand in the
center yeah I'm going to play
C6 which maybe looks counterproductive
because I'm allowing the bishop to move
somewhere where it won't be attacked by
the
knights the main idea is I want to play
this move Pawn
D5 the other main idea was I was
attacking the bishop and now I'm happy
to win the bishop with a knight and I
save my knight from the
pawn and that was a a very quick six
move
win um still maybe a couple lessons to
take away like don't bring out your
queen
early uh in this manner if if you if you
want to play like Prince principal
chess but then the point I wanted to
make is wherever the bishop was going to
move like let's say Bishop
C4 the plan was to play D5 and I really
wanted to remove this
Pawn not with the intention of taking
back but with intention of Bishop
F5 and then then the queen would be
exploited have another piece in play the
Queen moves anywhere I take on
C2 so hopefully another lesson to take
away how to punish such an
opening anyway I think I'll wrap the
episode up here for
YouTube so if you're watching on YouTube
thanks for watching don't forget to
follow on Twitch if you like the content
subscribe on Twitch if you have Amazon
Prime you can subscribe for free easy
way to support the channel get some
perks in the twitch chat also twitch
chat says hi maybe twitch chat says
great
explanation by
YouTube episodes
xlam okay now some people say
hi yeah till next
time